[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE WILLIAMS: Have you ever
wondered about the relationship
between two measures.
For example, what happens
to patient satisfaction
when people have longer wait times?
A scatter plot is a graphical
tool used to examine
the association between two measures.
It's a powerful tool for helping
us understand relationships
and associations between two variables.
Scatter plots can be helpful for doing
PDSA testing to understand variables
that might affect the project measures.
Scatter plots help us to
see unusual patterns, data
affected by special causes, and
interesting clustering of data points.
It also can show how changes in process
measures are affecting outcomes.
Here's an example of a scatter diagram
showing a negative relationship.
So let's imagine again
that we've got waiting time
in-- we'll put time
down here-- in minutes
and we're doing 10, 20, 30, 40, 50.
Make it straight arrow.
So this is the x-axis.
And then on the y-axis, we're
going to put satisfaction.
So we're doing 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
So this is our scatter plot.
All right.
So imagine as we're
looking at this and we
start collecting data from our patients
that we start to see a series of dots.
And as-- basically-- as time increases,
we see patient satisfaction decrease
and creates kind of a picture like this.
And we see data look this way, right?
So as the time is increasing, the
score-- the patient satisfaction
score-- is dropping.
We call this a negative relationship.
So if satisfaction scores
increased as time increased,
we would have a positive correlation.
If the dots are randomly
displayed like a shotgun blast,
we'd say there's no correlation.
One important thing to note
is relationship or correlation
is not the same as causation.
There are statistical tools
and methods to determine
whether relationship is due to chance
alone or statistically important.
Most commercial spreadsheet
programs have an option
to create a scatter plot.
Can you think of measures
related to a process
you're trying to improve that may
benefit from doing a scatter plot?